over the next few days president Trump
is slated to usher a bevy of Republicans
into the White House to wine and dine
them over Trump care the replacement
plan for Obamacare that looks much more
like Obamacare light then like an actual
Liberty based reform destined to free
Americans from regulatory burden and
allow them freedom of choice in a
competition based marketplace
undoubtedly some Republicans those most
in change from a primary challenge and
most fearful of Trumpy inventions will
cave but the whole scenario reveals a
few basic truths first president Trump
is not ideologically driven anyone who
thinks Trump is ideologically driven
rather than driven by desire for
popularity and power should be
disappointed by this Trump care rollout
Trump doesn't know what the details are
he clearly doesn't care very much his
plan is simple boil down the health care
choice here to to binary options option
one ram through this deeply flawed bill
that minimizes political harm to him by
trimming around the edges of Obamacare
while fitting to the base that has been
repealed and replaced option to push the
bills as hard as possible watch it fail
then blame Republicans for presenting
him with a flawed plan he pushed like a
good soldier and blame Democrats for
blocking much-needed reforms second
nobody knows anything about basic
communications from care was rolled out
amidst questions about secrecy just like
Obamacare it was rushed just like
Obamacare and when conservatives
objected to its provisions Speaker of
the House Paul Ryan and team Trump
answered but it's just part one of a
three-part plan question shouldn't you
have a lead with that you idiots if
you're going to throw out an unpopular
largely unworkable bill that adds to the
debt while continuing to undermine free
markets shouldn't you tell us what the
non crap in the craft hand which is
going to be but no also worth noting
Republicans don't have to do a massive
replacement package they could simply
pass repeal then pass a series of
shorter bills ended freeing the health
care market daniel horowitz over a
conservative review has a pretty good
summary of such actions third
congressional Republicans have no spine
it is no surprise to see congressional
Republicans on the verge of being wooed
by Trump with bowling in pizza yes
seriously bowling and pizza this allows
them to avoid responsibility Obamacare
like all other redistribution programs
has a set a specific beneficiaries in
diffuse victims which means it's more
politically popular than unpopular at
this point to keep big swathes of it
Trump care allows Republicans to do this
while blaming Trump but Republicans
elected in 2010 in 2014 they should be
wary of the blowback you can't keep from
the moon forever and then deliver some
moldy cheese as a replacement for Steve
benen is sitting pretty in the White
House our game is spandan versus
previous previous is the man allied with
paul ryan he's Ryan's man on the inside
attempting to shape policy by
coordinating with Congress Bannon is the
smash from all outsider who couldn't
care less about Congress hates Paul Ryan
and things previous is a gormless we'll
see boy however this thing now shakes
out Bannon is in solid position if Trump
care keeps getting crushed in the press
that's on previous if the thing passes
and it's unpopular that's on Priebus if
it falls apart that's on previous two
and bandhan can point to prevous and
whisper it in Trump's ear that if he'd
only followed his instincts all would
have been well well played Steve and and
well played fifth republicans lost the
health care argument because they aren't
willing to fight Republicans essentially
acknowledged by embracing main aspects
of Obamacare the leftist argument that
the government ought to be involved in
ensuring that everyone obtained health
insurance or health care that's crap as
I've explained before a market-based
system that recognizes free choice and
individual responsibility for health
decisions and that incentivizes lower
costs and higher supply through
preservation of Adam and structure will
not only work better it will represent a
commitment to Liberty spelled out in the
Constitution but it's always easier to
declare something right than to be
provided by government than to declare a
right to be free from government as
always Republicans have seated this
critical battlefield Trump care looks
bad for conservatives it isn't a major
improvement from Obamacare it represents
retreat from central conservative
principles it won't make Republicans
more popular but it does show how
cowardice and lack of principle result
in horrible policy i'm ben shapiro this
is the vin shapiro show
so I come back from legoland and
Disneyland with my wife and my daughter
and my son and you've ruined everything
you've ruined everything okay that's not
really true there's some good stuff
that's happening in the Trump
administration and then there's this
health care rollout which is a bit of a
disaster and there's the women's March
the day without a woman which shockingly
was not a day without women women were
everywhere in the press they were
wearing red and Lefty women were being
bothersome but we'll get to all of that
in just a second first we have to say
thank you to our sponsors over at legacy
box so one of the things that I care
about most in life is family memories
which is why I do things like go on
vacation with my wife in the middle of
the week and because I care about family
memories so much I've always been a big
advocate of making sure that you've
protected your photos and your old
videos all those memories they can
disappear so easily because you don't
remember everything that's happened in
your life but legacy box ensures that
all that the stack of old tapes that
you've never watched before all those
little pictures that are just moldering
out in the garage all of that can be
preserved and it can be put on an
easy-to-use thumb drive and put it on a
DVD for you so you can have access to it
right away you just take all your stuff
you dump it in a box from legacy box you
throw it to them and then you send it to
them and they take it they put barcodes
on it so that you can track every piece
that's been sent to them and then they
send you back a DVD or a thumb drive
with all the material on it so instead
of you having to worry that if there's a
flood or a fire or something goes wrong
in your house it's going to ruin all
your memories you've got it all
available digitally and at the touch of
a touch of a button so that's pretty
awesome legacy box make sure that it
happens if you go to legacy box calm
right now / Ben go to legacy box calm /
Ben you get a forty percent discount on
your order heavy discount great service
legacy box com / Ben legacy box calm /
been saying all those film reels and
photos that don't get watched or taken
out send them to legacy box and they'll
take care of all of it for you again its
legacy box com / Ben you get a forty
percent discount on your order very
important service something you should
certainly do for your family okay so
we'll begin today by talking about this
idiotic day without a woman routine that
happened yesterday it did not serve its
purposes so if you're going to hold what
they called a general strike if you're
going to hold a general strike general
strike just means everybody doesn't go
to work if we're going to hold the
general strike the purpose of the
general strike presumably is to show how
horrible things we
be if these women didn't show up to work
did anyone have a real rough time
yesterday when women didn't show up to
work this way it wasn't even a huge
percentage of women when a certain
number of women didn't show up to work
because they're left the idiot did did
the world stop turning did everything
implode no it didn't and so that sort of
undermines the idea of the general
strike in the first place also if they
are marching against the wage gap it
seems to me one way that you could help
close the wage gap is by working if you
take the day off and you don't get paid
and then you blame men well that's not
part of the so-called wage gap that's
you taking the day off plus you have to
acknowledge that there is a little bit
of income bias here the only people who
are going to take the day off our number
one people who can afford to take the
day off and number two people who aren't
working now everybody who actually has
to be at work was it work so a lot of
the people who showed up or members of
the American Federation of Teachers
which is it major public sector union or
the National Education Association
another major public union and it's easy
for them to do that because they're
basically striking against the
government what other things already
otic about this they the ancillary
causes in this date without a woman so
when the star sewer was arrested she is
the the radical Muslim spokesperson for
the women's March she was arrested at
the women's March for no apparent reason
but one of the events organisers was
also a lady named resmia you set Odette
who's a Palestinian terrorists convicted
of killing two israeli men in a
terrorist attack so she was there so
that's exciting often they talked about
abortion and what they called solidarity
with the sex workers rights movement
okay then that's weird okay so they were
they're very focused on the key issues
that matter my favorite story that came
out of the day without a woman was
according to the Washington Post some
feminists spent the day refusing to
smile seriously this is Washington Post
reporting some feminists saying the
happy face they sport by habit around
command it's a form of unpaid emotional
labor okay this is fake news feminists
don't smile so I'm not sure which
feminist they say the happy face they
score but has anyone ever seen a
feminist who sports a happy face by
habit the most miserable people on earth
self-described feminists who marching
things like this the happy face they
sport by habit my goodness yeah I always
think brightness and sunshine when I
think militant feminist that's always
what I think of also if you want to win
friends and influence
people don't call smiling emotional
labor it was anyone forcing you to
smiles and putting a gun to your head I
understand that in our society in a
civilization we try to be generally
pleasant to one another and I think
that's a good thing I think that it's
good that we are pleasant to one another
as a general rule it doesn't seem to me
to be unmona labor that people expect
you to be pleasant to one another
otherwise everybody then ever then do
you really want the world to work like
the TSA at LAX is that really what you
want the world to look like like people
glaring at you and getting angry at you
while they force you to stuff your
oversized baggage into that stupid
little metal thing is that what you want
the world to look like apparently some
that's what the world would work like
that also there are all these people
wearing red in solidarity for something
or other this is confusing here's a
montage of some of the people in media
wearing red you look at this look at all
these women wearing red women in science
technology engineering and then all
these women wearing red you know that
talking on CNN so you've got a bunch of
people when I went on and then you have
people on Fox and who's wearing red and
it's just like the huge number of people
wearing red wing NBC News there okay and
it just goes on and on and on all these
members of the media wearing red all
these women are going on okay ladies
turns out something we knew you were
ladies we did I know shocker we knew
your women and it doesn't help your case
when you wear ugly red cardigans or what
looks like a magic eye poster undershirt
that is red and it just goes on and on
again is that what statement are they
trying to make other than we are women
yet we know that's why you're on TV in
part okay women actually have a
relatively large advantage when it comes
to getting bookings on TV because people
like to look at women in ways they don't
like to look at men sorry to break it to
you ladies this is why pretty women are
on TV more often than not such pretty
women but you know they all the women on
TV wearing red oh well this demonstrates
their strength and power actually just
demonstrates that whoever had stock in
the in the red fabric died yesterday did
really really well they other things
that were idiotic Anne Hathaway you know
the super super wealthy actress she
spoke at the UN about equal pay and
Hathaway oh my goodness somehow we and
every American parents were expected to
be back to normal in under three months
without income I remember thinking to
myself if the practical reality of
pregnancy is another mouth to feed in
your home and America is a country where
most people are living paycheck to
paycheck how does 12 weeks unpaid leave
economically work the truth is for too
many people it doesn't one in four
American women go back to work two weeks
after giving birth because they can't
afford to take off any more time than
that okay and that's why I have an idea
for you I have an idea you see that very
very very expensive blazer that you're
wearing how much that cost how much paid
leave could you provide to a poor
working mother if you just sold that
very very expensive blazer and then used
it for the paid maternity leave you can
do it it's a free country here's what I
don't understand so much I don't
understand why you know I have a wife we
have two children my wife took maternity
leave with both our kids not paid
maternity leave just maternity leave and
we covered it because that's what we do
we decided that was a decision we wanted
to make as a family I don't understand
why it's incumbent on my wife now to
work longer hours and see her kid less
so that other people can have paid
maternity leave also worth noting most
companies now grant paid maternity leave
most companies you make sure that there
is a paid maternity leave are paid
parental leave if a major corporation
most are offering this because they
understand it's a competitive way of
grabbing up labor of grabbing up solid
labor but i love these uber-wealthy
celebrities who sit there and act like
there's nothing that can be done for
these poor women who can't take
maternity leave and half the way it gets
paid millions of dollars to act in
movies okay she's perfectly capable of
helping out these people but instead
it's got to be the government forcing it
or the government taxing people in order
to do and then she takes off her money
i'm sure and stashes it in an overseas
bank accounts that it doesn't actually
have to be taxed in the united states
just like all these people in Hollywood
do so that is just delightful others
other aspects of the day without a woman
again it was just it was you so it was a
long litany of irritation other things
but this was a mature celebrated was
there's a statue I guess somebody put up
of this little girl staring down the
bowl and on Wall Street okay and the
bull on Wall Street is supposed to
represent Wall Street and there is this
statue of this brave little girl
standing
a ball a couple of facts that should be
noted here one little girls please do
not stand in front of enraged bull it's
just not smart okay don't take this
literally i feel this warning has to be
issued because we now live in a world
where people make movies about how this
little girl has superpowers and could
punch the bull into the next County in
reality that bowl would trample the
little girl and it would be very sad and
terrible so please parents don't let
your little girls standing from the bolt
okay let's put that out there number two
what exactly should facing down Wall
Street Wall Street is bad to women Wall
Street America is the greatest country
for women in the history of humanity and
that's largely because we have a
thriving market place including Wall
Street what is little girl floorstanding
for communism is she standing against
table again all of this is just images
of female strength hmm let's let's talk
about female strength in the context of
what wouldn't actually do they work
instead of going on stupid marches they
bare children and bring up those
children as opposed to asking the
government to do so and they actually
take place in a marketplace as opposed
to standing against the marketplace
that's a big Jew in America and that's
what makes women fantastic in America is
not make the feminist movement fantastic
finally Hillary Clinton felt the
necessity to come out of hiding
apparently she had her hair done by the
same people who did instincts here and
and she I don't know what happened to
that it did not look like that when it
came in the mail but now she's just
donning this this wig dude it looks like
some sort of it's like she said I don't
know it's like a dead parrot on her head
in any case Hillary Clinton did a
snapchat for the children you know that
snapchat for the children and she and
she talked about what women are supposed
to do while wearing I get a very
expensive jacket that is painted red
there's a lot to fight for Planned
Parenthood education health care jobs
every issue is a woman's issue so Santa
resist run for office be a champion I
can't believe we didn't elect this woman
how did we not elect this bag of
charisma this giant oversized bag of
charismatic genius wow how did we not
make her president I can't freaking
imagine further no one should just stand
up and resist Hillary women tried to
resist your husband didn't let them ok
so just putting that be ok so before we
get to the actual breakdown in health
care because that I think is just as
important
again this just demonstrates what
doesn't know what the hell they're doing
they're terrible at everything and they
demonstrated each and every day before
we get to what republicans suck at which
is apparently replacing Obamacare and
repealing Obamacare we have to say thank
you to our sponsors / and my patriot
supply so right now if you are concerned
about the possibility of war or natural
disaster and you should be i mean
everyone should always be concerned
about these possibilities you should
make sure that you go to my patriots
supply and prepare with ben commie going
to prepare with ben com or 888 803 1413
8888 0 3 14 13 and you get night for
ninety nine dollars plus free shipping
you get a huge supply of all the food
that you're going to need in case of
something terrible happening it's a
four-week emergency food supply it's
limited to 22 per person so you know you
don't have to worry about you know
you're going to buy a thousand of them
you don't need a thousand of them it's a
four-week food supply emergency food
supply and that ensures that you and
your family are taken care of in case of
a natural disaster or some sort of
emergency if you're concerned again
about terror attack or tornado if you're
worried about earthquake or flood then
you have to have food in your home and
my team has tasted they tell me that the
meals actually tastes surprisingly good
you know it's canned food and it
maintains for like 25 years it stays
forever but they say that it actually
tastes pretty good with your shocking
considering the conditions but again
you're buying this for emergencies
investments go to prepare with been calm
right now prepare with been calm right
now be prepared for emergency
preparedness calm 8888 03 14 13 8 8 8 8
03 14 13 make sure that you and your
family are prepared in case of emergency
so you may have noticed from the top of
the show that I'm very very critical of
the of the new Obamacare replacement and
the reason I'm critical of the Obama
care placement is because it absolutely
sucks okay they're a bunch of problems
with the Obamacare placement the biggest
problem with the Obamacare replacement
that is being proposed the sort of Trump
care or Ryan care friends of Trump call
it Ryan care for parents of Ryan call a
trump care I'm gonna call it from care
because the president gets credit for
the health plan he's proposing okay we
didn't call it pelosi care who's called
obamacare so it seems fair to me that
we're going to call it Trump care now
especially since Trump keeps saying how
wonderful it is Trump just tweeted out
minutes ago quote despite what you hear
in the press health care is coming alone
great we are talking to many many groups
it will end in a
a beautiful picture of like a pony like
beautiful picture of like a doggy like I
dunno what that means but ok I'll tell
you what's not a beautiful picture is
the actual thing so I've looked at the
bill there are a bunch of problems with
the bill first thing to note about this
this Obamacare bill the free market is a
great structure the minute you start
intervening in the free market the
minute you poke your thumb in in order
to quote unquote fix the free market you
start a chain effect you start a domino
reaction that which you have to get more
and more and more involved in the market
and this is a perfect case in point so
this all starts from the premise that
insurance companies are well because
insurance companies will not cover
pre-existing conditions or they will
charge you more if you have a
pre-existing condition this makes sense
as I have explained one bajillion times
on this program because again if you
have an insurance company you don't
insure things that have already happened
that's not an insurance company anymore
now that's just a pyramid scheme okay if
I burn down my house and then apply for
fire insurance no one will grant me fire
insurance because the house has already
been burned down they're not going to
say hey sounds great pay us a hundred
dollars a month and we will pay you
100,000 dollars for the house you just
burn down they won't do that because
that's stupid okay the economy can't
work that way and yet we are all
fighting mad about the pre-existing
condition stuff here's the fact about
pre-existing conditions the reason
health insurance is useful is because
you're supposed to buy it before you
have a pre-existing condition and you're
supposed to buy it for your family
you're supposed to have prenatal health
insurance you're supposed to do all
these things so we don't have to worry
about the pre-existing conditions that
exist right because then it won't be a
preexisting condition it will just be a
condition that is the purpose okay and
anything that refuses to acknowledge
this problem ends up completely skewing
and destroying the insurance market
that's exactly what has happened here
then up regulating the living crap out
of the insurance companies then you have
to subsidize it because the cost is
higher and then those subsidies don't
work because people don't take the
subsidies instead what they do is they
sit around waiting for the pre-existing
condition to materialize and then they
jump into the insurance market skewing
the cost so fear it further creating
what you call the death spiral in the
insurance market again all that starts
from one simple premise insurance
companies are even did't evil right
they're terrible terrible terrible
because they won't cover pre-existing
conditions so Republicans because they
are stupid instead of recognizing that
the government really does not have a
place in the health insurance market it
really doesn't okay
should not be part of the health
insurance market if the government is
going to be involved anywhere the
government should be involved only to
the extent that it is necessary to
prevent communicable disease for example
if there's an epidemic because that has
externalities but if you are just
somebody who is too stupid to get health
insurance your entire life and now you
have heart disease and now you want the
government to take care of you know the
answer is no okay because the fact is
then the free competitive market health
insurance would have been available
since you were young and you can afford
it if you had a steady job okay that is
the truth in the United States of
America or you saved up the money in
some sort of health savings account
here's the reality okay the people talk
about you know poverty being the lead
indicator of not having health insurance
that's true poverty is also a leading
indicator that you're not making
particularly financially sound decisions
and so anything that is geared toward
forcing poor people to make financially
sound decisions is not going to work
very well because poor people who are
permanently poor I'm not talk about
people who are temporarily poor okay
that happens people lose their jobs we
need to fix the health insurance system
so far as government regulates it that
it's connected to your employer as
opposed to being freely available to
individuals k that was a government
outgrowth to begin with again another
case of the government getting involved
or wasn't wanted and that creating all
sorts of terrible externalities once you
do that you end up destroying the health
marketing to talk about government being
involved however there are certain
places for government to be involved in
minimizing government involvement so
that we can get toward a better system
there will have to be a transition here
now if Paul Ryan and Donald Trump and
come forward and said this is a
transitional part of the plan so we can
move toward a totally free market that
would be one thing they didn't then
presenting this is part one of a
three-part plan first of all as I said
earlier they didn't even mention it was
part one of a three-part plan originally
they acted like this was the whole thing
okay which is just idiotic if you're
going to feed me a crap sandwich at
least tell me there's some meat in it
not just crap unfortunately the original
bill was basically just crap so there
are a few problems first of all again it
retains all the requirements that
insurance cover people with pre-existing
conditions once you remove that leg of
the free market stool the rest of it
just collapses then in order to make
sure that it pays for itself you have to
force people to buy health insurance so
how are they doing that they're taking
away the mandate but they're now
mandating they have a different mandates
the mandate is that insurance companies
have to charge you a 30-percent
surcharge a 30-percent fine for those
whose insurance has lapsed and so that's
the second problem it
so creates individual healthcare
subsidies so if your high risk you have
pre-existing conditions well we give you
money to buy health insurance which of
course drives up the price of health
insurance because you have additional
demand okay it also subsidizes Medicaid
for a greater period of time until 2020
it subsidizes Medicaid allows States to
expand their roles which is not good
because if you think if you think that a
future Congress is going to allow cuts
to Medicaid you're out of your mind
there's never been an entitlement
program that has had significant cuts
from Congress without significant
bravery and finally it subsidizes
high-risk pools on the state level a lot
of people like this they say okay if we
give a hundred billion dollars two
states over the next ten years then it
will help them cover all of these costs
and they can figure out how to use that
money again if you think that's going to
disappear you are totally wrong because
again anybody who vows to spend more
money on this sort of stuff is going to
win elections which would require
political bravery now this would be a
good time this would be a good time for
Donald Trump to use that political
bravery so is he going to do that well
we shall discuss that thing but you will
first have to go to daily wire.com to
check it out because we have a lot more
to discuss plus a thing that I
absolutely hate happening right here
inside the office i love it and i hate
it I've never loved and hated anything
so much but you'll have to go to daily
wire calm eight dollars months will
allow you to become a subscriber to
daily wire com+ you become an annual
subscriber get a free copy of the arroyo
which is a fictional film set its DVD
copies fictional film set on the border
all about the border crisis that's
happening on our southern border and and
right now by the way Trump doing a good
job of shutting that down which is
pretty cool but you can get that DVD
copy by becoming an annual subscriber
plus the Shapiro store I keep promising
it but it is it is coming I promise and
that is the promise that will be
fulfilled daily wired.com they become a
subscriber or listen later at SoundCloud
or iTunes and make sure that you leave a
review at iTunes and check it out so we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
you